five days after suffering a massive
stroke at his home in Los Angeles
Beverly Hills 90210 star Luke Perry
died yesterday and he was just 52 years
old Perry was surrounded by friends and
family including his two young children
dr. Terra nurullah is here for a medical
perspective on strokes but first
Entertainment Tonight co-host Kevin
Frazier looks back at an actor whose
name became synonymous with a zip code
if the city of Beverly Hills wasn't
already famous around the world you know
the tragedy of this country is the
cretins like you to end up running it
Luke Perry helped put it on the map by
playing bad boy heartthrob Dylan McKay
between 1990 and 2000 condolences from
his friends and nine oh two one oh
co-stars flooded the internet Monday I
and ziering tweeted I will forever bask
in the loving memories we've shared over
the last 30 years that is a bad guy can
we go please in the midst of his TV
stardom Perry tried to avoid typecasting
first starring in the big screen version
of Buffy the Vampire Slayer then playing
a world champion bull rider in the film
8 seconds your mom and I are trying to
decide between pizza and Chinese food he
made a successful return to television
in early 2017 playing the father of the
main character in riverdale the show
temporarily shut down production on
Monday you guys are going to dance
together we were talking about real-life
fatherhood inspired him to change his
health regimen after a cancer scare four
years ago I'm a father of two children I
want to be with them as long as I can I
want to have his healthy life as I can
spend as much time with him his death
cut that time tragically short and came
as a shock to anyone who remembers him
as the youthful rebel who epitomized the
1990s like all television series Nano
too will come and it will go you know
there's gonna come a day when they're
gonna say that's it that's your last
episode for CBS this morning Kevin
Frazier Los Angeles our dr. taryn Rula
is here now to talk about the health
behind this doctor 52 years old
Perry was is that uncommon is that
extraordinary so I think one of the
misconceptions is that strokes are a
disease of the elderly but what I
want to convey is that this can happen
to anyone at any age and while we know
that the risk of stroke does increase if
you're over 65 right three-quarters of
strokes happen in populations over 65
the risk doubles every 10 years over the
age of 55 there's still a fair
percentage of people who have strokes in
their younger ages we also have seen an
increase in the incidence of strokes in
a younger population now whether that's
because we're diagnosing them more often
or because there's an increase in risk
factors things like high blood pressure
and obesity and diabetes that's driving
it it's really unclear but the big
message to young people is look you need
to understand that you're at risk
understand what your risk factors are
and importantly recognize symptoms
because time is brain every minute that
goes by in a large stroke you lose two
million brain cells and this damage is
irreversible and so you know it's very
important to act on symptoms even if you
think they go away even if you think
they're not a big deal you need to get
to the hospital because our treatments
require intervention in a short window
of time so things like what symptoms
like numbness or tingling in an arm or
leg inability to see well or confusion
or trouble walking or difficulty with
your speech or facial droop lack of
coordination massive headache any of
those things and 80% of strokes are
preventable yes I'm not okay exactly so
controlling blood pressure which is very
important stopping smoking controlling
your weight - exercise all the same
things we talked about for heart disease
thank you thank you very much - is very
surprising though to get that news
yesterday mm-hmm
thank you